you get one life compassion make the
thing is that I want to really learn
spanish but getting used to having a
choice getting used to do it all back to
being independent from traffic jams plus
being most effective there are morning
hours these good things made me think
that ok after some short experiment of
going to do these glasses and having
liquid Spanish classes five times a week
I can do it more effectively one day
from this public course which I'm going
will give me my almost one week of the
effective glasses hope that will show I
didn't resign from this public course at
all so I got a chance to come back there
I know what I'm missing I know what Matt
but season order to learn I gotta have
tons of materials and comment online
that they can use the thing is that I
have to be I have to be systematic this
with learning coding designs Spanish is
important for me that's not the priority
the priority
learning to code everybody Haskell just
11 life and everybody has the same 24
hours so the thing the thing is how do
you manage in time the thing is have
expanded so far this is cool and knowing
your clothes knowing your energy clothes
it's really important to learn more
effectively and if you don't know your
priorities and you take the life as it
comes you don't use it wisely I prefer
being aware i prefer to be on my own and
conducting some experiments not being
afraid to change the decision and try
something new if it goes with my
priorities if it's okay with what i will
achieve in life it's tuesday and we're
searching how to present the design
section and i've discovered that the
project that i wanted to show already
have some problems it seems that the API
has been changed this is the minus when
designing stuff and implementing the
code that's connected with the API that
does not belong to you all of a sudden
it can change and you gotta change your
coat it's Wednesday I want to show my
design skills and portfolio but I'm not
sure how to do it was the best way which
predicts to choose how to describe them
some of them I cannot show and this is
the problem when happen the a and you
did something for plans you are proud of
but you cannot show it so so I'm
wondering how to do it and what to show
so
no idea right now maybe welcome today
the later on during the day no meetings
lefty
[Music]
an hour and a half Academy Teen Center
it would be the meeting with another
freak old camper but she's from Sevilla
and she is on her trail to Monica that's
why we decided to meet so that about our
called and provides into this and the
second anyway I'm going to have today is
with the product designer I hope to show
him also a bit my portfolio and to ask
about some advice the main reason that
that we are meeting hall is to discuss
his talk there in front of moraga
amitabh is focused on front end and
design and says he has a lot of
experience I hope he would share it with
the rest of the community
[Music]
it's Wednesday in the evening I just
came back from the two meetings that I
had first I was with free code camper
and from Cydia we were revising our
crowd and we were discussing our design
and learning from ourselves so I I got
discovered few things from the free to
die and JavaScript it was really awesome
meeting really productive one I learned
a lot the second thing I had it was
really motivating when it comes to the
person the story and his experience he
is the designer and with about 20 years
of experience and I really enjoyed this
meeting because of many aspects and he
he motivated me a lot to learn design
and to try harder and this was really a
very awesome and meeting the people had
who are also doers meaning the people
who have that interesting story to share
and who try hard to develop to live real
live and to to do a lot of stuff not
just only to spend their life passively
it's really motivating driving your
ghost helps and if you see the quipu who
we're on the same path but few years ago
or who are at the same time right now
it's um it can be motivating it can be
inspiring you can learn a lot and you
can take the energy from it for your
fight one more take away if you're
watching this but you're the person with
a lot of experience who can share their
story these struggles they have do not
hesitate to share it you choose the farm
it may be the article may be the video
it may be that posted whatever you want
showing us something awesome you don't
have to do it nobody will make you do it
but it it can help so many people
thursday i want to have too much time
today too we're going to code itself but
i decided to work on the materials and
the content for the design section and
for sure I reiterating over it and
changing the projects adding the staff
with time so what is the time that I
have today for creating the content for
taking out the best example recording
some movies for deciding how to tell the
story and what to focus on it's friday
i'm doing cross browser testing and
checking also the page on various
devices
it's Saturday in the evenings is how the
page looks right now so I introduced
smooth scrolling
working on portfolio sections I
introduced on the mob mock-ups it's
easier to focus on the design right now
the page is available at the one who
does right now I starting to introduce
some changes like add the designer in
terms of design cases I'm working on I
want to correct a bit the routines here
I will also need to run the speed test
and optimize the images and generally
that CSS JavaScript and things like that
and what I did this week was fasting
probably the page and fixing some parts
you think I also have to make an
inspiring meetings and I was revising
the code of ethics project those are
small changes learning that basic stuff
like the beginnings those meeting of
deeply and how can I should start with
it next week I'm going to analyze the
state machine and how it works because
it seems to be pretty useful and
understanding the stage and programming
the logic and in various apps I will be
also working on the next page of the
design project I can show you that but
it will take me some time but hopefully
i will also learn something new and i
will be able to share it with you
keep on moving and see you next week
[Music]